well if we talk about what is it that we
should train children and adults because
I think we need lifelong education to do
it's not rote learning which
unfortunately is still the model of
Education throughout much of the world I
think actually United States is better
than a lot of other areas in terms of
having more flexible approaches to what
it is we're trying to get children to do
many areas of the world are really still
have a model of Education of rote
learning which is obsolete because we
carry all that information on our belts
who don't need to remember it all but we
do need to be able to solve actual
problems with knowledge we need to find
the right knowledge yes we have search
engines to help us and the search
engines will get better but really need
the right strategies to find the right
information we need to be able to create
new knowledge knowledge is doubling its
every 13 months by some measures and
knowledge isn't just a database
knowledge is a symphony or a jazz band
or a poem or novel or new scientific
insight or an invention those are these
are also examples of knowledge my
falsity of education is learned by doing
singularity University which I
co-founded with Peter Diamandis and
Chancellor of has that philosophy where
the core curriculum is the students self
organized into small teams and they take
on a grand challenge like to solve the
water problem of the world you know
maybe they will actually succeed in
doing that the goal is to actually do
solve major challenges in ten years or
maybe they'll solve a piece of it or
maybe they won't solve it at all but
they'll still learn something if I think
about what I've learned in my career
it's from my own projects and whether
they succeed or fail that's really the
best way to learn and there's versions
of that we can bring into every level we
certainly see many college kids starting
major revolutions including political
revolutions but also technological
revolution
with no equipment other than their
notebook computer